ja jahrzehntelang tappten die ermittler
im dunklen pkw wurde von 29 jahren
ermordet eine leiche wurde aber nie
gefunden jetzt wurden drei männer
festgenommen
mein kollege stephan mayer kennt die
details zu diesem fall sondern wie kam
jetzt dieser durchbruch in einem so
alten fall ja die polizei spricht von
hinweisen aus dem umfeld nach unseren
informationen ist es so dass einer der
beschuldigten im bekanntenkreis die tat
angedeutet hat daraufhin hat eine
ermittlungsgruppe september ihre arbeit
aufgenommen und hat drei männer
beobachtet
es soll telefonüberwachung gegeben haben
und jetzt verhaftet man hat pcs und
mobiltelefone beschlagnahmt und drei
männer verhaftet den einen in berlin und
zwei im saarland in den kleineren
gemeinden riegelsberg und heusweiler
alle drei sitzen jetzt in u-haft und
sagen aber nichts zur tat
gerade ein altes foto von peter g
gesehen dem opfer was weiß man über ihn
von 29 jahren ist der verschwundene gibt
es jetzt zumindest die hoffnung endlich
die leiche zu finden
ja er wurde zuletzt am 17 september in
völklingen
gesehen auf dem parkplatz eines
einkaufsmarktes damals wir haben
recherchiert wurde gesagt dass besonders
auffällig bei ihm tätowierungen an den
armen und am rücken sind
danach hat man
keine spur mehr von ihm gehabt bis jetzt
knapp 30 jahre nach seinem verschwinden
man hat hoffnung dass man ihn findet wir
sind hier in wadgassen in einem kleinen
in einer kleinen gemeinde bei saarlouis
im saarland
hier sollen die drei ihnen getötet
ermordet haben und auch vergraben haben
noch finden keine grabungen statt
kleiner arbeiten die polizei hat aber
gesagt demnächst vermutlich noch in
dieser woche wird hier begonnen nach der
leiche zu suchen die es noch nicht gibt
also bisher ist es ein mord ohne leiche